the most exciting thing that's going to
be happening as we're ending 2018
spider-man into the spider verse comes
out December 14th but we've got a few
exciting updates that'll hopefully tide
you over these next two weeks first up
the Stan Lee cameo this movie is the
first Stan Lee cameo to be released
posthumously and features an animated
version of Stan Lee as a New York City
merchant he offers miles some advice at
a key moment and gives him a special
help some possibly but also we've got
some cool spin-off news a spider women
movie has been announced it's going to
be about three generations of quim and
with spider powers it looks like Phil
Lord and Chris Miller will be involved
which is super exciting makes me very
happy about this and people are thinking
that it'll probably include spider-gwen
who will be voiced by Hailee Steinfeld
in into the spider verse the Spider
Woman film is in addition to a sequel
that is already in the works I think
we've got another cinematic universe on
our hands boys and girls very excited
yeah and what are the three that they've
said they've mentioned some of the
characters it might be oh yeah there's a
lot of exciting news for Spider Woman
the initial like the grumbling rumblings
I heard were that Spider Woman the
original Jessica drew who her powers are
so confusing she can fly right no idea
why not a clue and she has like an
electric zap spiders can't fly but what
do you guys want to see where you guys
want to see them take these stories and
which ladies do you want to see in the
spider women movie also Madame web who's
been interpreted a few different ways in
like animated cartoons or comics she's
just an older
Spider Woman and then a Spider Girl as
well who can there's a character named
araña who's really interesting and there
is like a mate a Parker who's just a
younger like child of Peter Parker and
Mary Jane so there's different things
you can do also there's also silk I'm a
big fan of silk
yeah weren't they gonna do a silk movie
that's may they pull the plug on it no
no this immunity show it's in there
weird
yeah I think it's exciting you know like
if you're gonna go in a new direction
that's gonna be different from the MCU
yeah let's see what these guys vitae man
seems to be killing it at the moment I
mean it had its absent flows but the
latest Tom Holland iteration of
spider-man's the best we've seen
I feel the latest video game despite a
video game like he's a frontrunner for
game of the year and I've heard every
single person that watched that movie
said it's probably one of the best
movies I've seen there's my venom
hundred million dollars so we can't
really we can say whatever you want but
money talks
yeah but yeah this movie is a left this
theater overjoyed okay also cool there's
Laura Montgomery and Joaquin dos Santos
who are both amazingly talented
directors and fight choreographers for
animated features they worked on while
Keane worked on Justice League Unlimited
but I believe Laura and Joaquim worked
on Avatar The Last Airbender Peeta Korra
Legend of Korra and Voltron for Netflix
and all those TV shows are incredible
one of the best parts about how they
direct action is that they're able to
like in animation you're supposed to be
able to do whatever you want and if you
guys watch like the DC animated movie
sometimes that means like they do
everything and you're like it's too much
yeah I can't see they perfectly know how
to capture it and how to tell it like a
compelling story so walking those
Santa's is up to possibly direct the
sequel and that makes me very good boy
and I'm happy that you called in - oh
yeah and too fast and too furious spider
for oh and there's the power - and Peter
and miles are doing this on the on the
cover you're welcome and there's a
thumbnail that is fun to see if this is
animated right like if the how
successful is this I think there's
something about animation it allows you
to get the tone just right with these
things and allow if it is a comic book
it's like a movie in comic book you know
like if you're doing comic book
adaptations let's experiment with some
animated features right he can do that
wouldn't it be cool if they did animated
shorts with like spider hands as the
cartoon like what if they do like a
little yeah
yeah whatever style yeah spectacular
spider-man remember Nickelodeon did that
one was that like 2008 something like
that Oh minute ago
a watt although well Eddie these well
let us know where you were a decade ago
tonight going to different people for
some of you but yeah let's know what you
want to see from this news spider-verse
the Sony verse and how you want it to be
different from the MCU version of
spider-man because that's that's great
but there's other ways to skin a spider
as you know in Australia clothes out
there